liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
deutsche bundestag unser land trauert um
helmut schmidt der am vergangenen
dienstag in hamburg im alter von 96
jahren verstorben ist
wer diese außergewöhnliche
persönlichkeit begreifen und würdigen
will muss die perspektive weiten auch
zeitlich gestern haben viele unserer
nachbarn an das ende des ersten
weltkrieges 1918 erinnert um zu erfassen
welche jahrhundert gestalt mit helmut
schmidt von uns gegangen ist reicht es
fast aus daran zu erinnern dass er nur
wenige wochen später noch im gleichen
jahr 1918 geboren wurde helmut schmidt
war ein kind der weimarer republik
erlebte seine jugend unterm hakenkreuz
und ihm selbst wurde der zweite
weltkrieg zum schicksal
die bedeutung dieser prägenden
erfahrungen in einem wie er in der ihm
eigenen befreienden deutlichkeit zu
sagen pflegte scheiß krieg hat er immer
wieder betont schmid kämpfte als soldat
in der sowjetunion später an der
westfront und geriet kurzfristig in
britische kriegsgefangenschaft
wir alle wollten damals nicht altes
einreißen
da gab es gar nichts mehr einzureißen
erinnerte er sich an den
gestaltungswillen seiner generation nach
kriegsende
wir wollten etwas neues aufbauen
bereits 1953 saß helmut schmidt erstmals
im deutschen bundestag den er über drei
jahrzehnte angehörte
schon bald nach seiner ersten wahl
zählte er zu den profiliertesten
vertretern der jüngeren generation im
parlament die militär und
sicherheitspolitik wurde zu seinem
eigentlichen metier
es ist deshalb nicht ohne symbolik
das heute genau vor 60 jahren die
bundeswehr gegründet wurde
wir haben gestern abend vor dem
reichstagsgebäude daran erinnert helmut
schmidt war der armee und den soldaten
in besonderer weise verbunden als
verteidigungsminister der erste
sozialdemokrat in diesem amt reformierte
er 1969 im kabinett von willy brandt die
streitkräfte die universität der
bundeswehr trägt auch deshalb heute
seinen namen aufbau und ausrichtung der
bundeswehr waren auch nach der
entscheidung zur wiederbewaffnung weiter
hoch umstritten
schmidt selbst profilierte sich in
dieser zeit als entschiedener gegner
einer atomaren bewaffnung
damals entstand das bild das die
öffentlichkeit lange vorrangig mit ihm
verband und das erst in seiner amtszeit
als minister und regierungschef und
später als elder statesman in den
hintergrund trat das ist scharfzüngigen
debattenredner aber nicht nur ein großer
redner sondern vor allem ein
leidenschaftlicher und ansteckender
gelegentlich provozierender debattierer
wie aus dem lehrbuch des
parlamentarismus pathos war seine sache
nicht er suchte lieber die bissigen
pointen die er meisterlich zu setzen
wusste seine rededuelle mit ludwig
erhard franz josef strauß und später
helmut kohl in denen er teil schneidende
attacken ritt sind unvergessen
zitat ich bilde mir ein durch viele
reden auch im bundestag eine ganze menge
moralischer und auch geistiger pflöcke
eingeschlagen zu haben
wusste er sich und sein redetalent
richtig einzuschätzen
einige von denen haben auch wirkung
erzielt ergänzte er
und das bestätigen nicht nur die die ihn
im hohen hause noch leibhaftig erlebt
haben
verbindendes element zwischen dem
leidenschaftlichen streit redner und dem
kühlen analytiker in der
regierungsverantwortung war die lust
daran argumentativ zu überzeugen durch
rede und widerrede
schmidt war so hat sigmar gabriel das
anlässlich seines 95 geburtstages
treffend ausgedrückt eine autorität die
sich auf das argument stützte in seiner
amtszeit als bundeskanzler hatte helmut
schmidt große herausforderungen zu
bewältigen
von der wirtschaftsrezession der 1970 er
jahre bis zu deutschlands rolle im
kalten krieg klarsichtig und
entschlossen trat er sie gemeistert
früher als andere hatte er die bedrohung
durch neue atomare mittelstreckenwaffen
der sowjetunion erkannt und voller
überzeugung für den nato doppelbeschluss
gestritten wider den zeitgeist der
damals seinen ausdruck in einer der
größten demonstrationen im deutschland
der nachkriegszeit fand populär war
diese politik nicht weder in der eigenen
partei noch in der öffentlichkeit
unvergessen ist seine standfestigkeit im
sogenannten deutschen herbst schmidt sah
sich damals vor unausweichliche
entscheidungen gestellt die er nicht
treffen konnte ohne schuld auf sich zu
laden
ihr dasselbe später bekannt hat aber er
hat sich nicht weggeduckt wären auf
zeitgenössischen aufnahmen sieht wer ihn
über diese wochen und monate reden hörte
spürt förmlich die bürde seines amtes
kann erahnen welche spuren sie auch bei
ihnen den vermeintlich so kühlen
pragmatiker hinterlassen hat dank seiner
entschlossenheit bestand unserer
republik ihre schwerste belastungsprobe
ohne selbst die freiheit zu gefährden
gegen die der terror gerichtet war
helmut schmidt erwarb sich damals hohes
vertrauen und ansehen
und das nicht allein in deutschland das
ihn als inbegriff des nüchternen
disziplinierten hanseaten verehrte in
der ganzen welt genoss helmut schmidt
höchste reputation als staatsmann der
deutsche politik berechenbar gemacht hat
weil sie auf nüchternheit und
rationalität toleranz und weltoffenheit
beruhte die spontane würdigung durch den
französischen ministerpräsidenten und
die abgeordneten in der französischen
nationalversammlung nach bekanntwerden
des todes von helmut schmidt am
vergangenen dienstag sind ein
eindrucksvoller beleg dieser
persönlichen wertschätzung wie der
besonderen beziehungen zwischen unseren
beiden ländern
und ich möchte die gelegenheit gerne
nutzen mich bei unseren französischen
kolleginnen und kollegen dafür
ausdrücklich zu bedanken
als ich helmut schmidt 1986 aus dem
bundestag verabschiedete verband er das
mit einem eindringlichen appell an die
parlamentarier zur besinnung auf das
ethos eines politischen pragmatismus in
moralischer absicht das kann man
durchaus auch für eine passende
orientierung für die aktuelle
flüchtlingskrise halten das was wir
erreichen was wir tun wollen soll und
moralisch begründet sein
der weg dahin müsse aber realistisch er
dürfe nicht illusionär sein
und er fügte für ihn fast untypisch
emphatisch hinzu zitat es sollte keiner
glauben dass solche etwas die
politischen ziele ihres glanzes beraube
oder den politischen alltag seines
feuers die erreichung des moralischen
ziels verlangt pragmatisches vernunft
gemäss politisches handeln schritt für
schritt und die vernunft erlaubt uns
zugleich doch auf diesem wege ein
unvergleichliches pathos
denn keine begeisterung sollte größer
sein als die nüchterne leidenschaft zur
praktischen vernunft dass der bundestag
früher als andere die überragende
bedeutung dieses parlamentariers erkannt
hatte
kommt auch in der souveränität zum
ausdruck ihm für seine abschiedsrede
eine alle proportionen auch die von
regierungserklärungen sprengende
redezeit von knapp zwei stunden
zuzubilligen die protokolle des
deutschen bundestages benötigen für die
aufzeichnung dieser rede 16 seiten und
nach zeitgenössischen berichten soll er
mit einem manuskript von 100 seiten ans
podium gegangen sein
cora moralischer ernst prägte das
selbstverständnis dieses herausragenden
politikers es ist sein bleibendes
vermächtnis noch in diesem jahr sagte er
von sich in demonstrativer hanseatischer
bescheidenheit ich bin kein vorbild das
ist eine rolle die mir nicht gefällt
allerdings machten im allenfalls
militante nichtraucher in dieser
einschätzung folgen
die meisten menschen faszinierte seine
immense lebenserfahrung
sie bewunderten seinen scharfen verstand
nicht zuletzt liebten sie seinen
trockenen humor
für viele war er in vorträgen als autor
und mitherausgeber der zeit bis zuletzt
die politische debatte und kontroverse
suchte
mit seiner meinung ein unverzichtbarer
kompass helmut schmidt war politiker
publizist und patriot als parlamentarier
als bundesminister und vor allem als
bundeskanzler hat er sich auf
herausragende weise um deutschland
verdient gemacht
wir verneigen uns vor einem der
bedeutendsten politischen und
intellektuellen köpfe unseres landes
unsere gedanken sind bei seiner familie
seinen freunden und weggefährten
vielen dank